Last week, you said you weren't a fan of black pepper because it makes everything in your gut absorb better.
Is this the same thing, is the same thing true of red hot peppers or hot red pepper flakes?
No, no, so it was discovered years ago that black pepper helped you absorb different nutrients.
So they actually started putting black pepper because it would take a step back.
Many nutrients in the nutraceutical industry over the years have been discovered to be great for certain things.
But the problem was the form of that nutrient that was available at the time, many times with many of the different nutrients was not really well absorbed.
It was like glutathione as an example. Probably about 15 years ago, the form of glutathione that we used with patients, not with our cancer patients, forever.
But what we used with fiber myelogen autoimmune patients and things was not readily absorbed.
So we used to create, in our clinic, we used to make our own liposomal glutathione for the sake of absorbability.
Are we used to have people nebulize glutathione, dissolve it in a liquid water and then nebulize it in order to increase the absorption?
Well, then over time they started increasing the, you know, battery, the product itself with different testing and absorbability of different nutrients and glutathione in our example has gone through multiple different changes in the product, multiple endpoint product that is distributed and sold.
And now glutathione, even in L, glutathione is much more absorbable.
Now they also have liposomal glutathione things. So it's much more absorbable.
But during this time, they found that black pepper helped things absorb.
And one of the studies was done on curcumin and black pepper and it really increased absorbability.
So a lot of companies added black pepper to their curcumin and I'm not against using black pepper in your curcumin.
But if you're adding black pepper to a lot of different supplements that you're taking, you will increase the absorbability of other things that are in the gut, maybe things you don't want to absorb.
So you have to be careful with that.
So, but that is not true with hot pepper, cayenne pepper and red pepper flakes so you're safe with those.